this episode is sponsored by audible to
get started go to audible.com slash
micro cosmos or text micro cosmos to 500
500
[Music]
there's something you've probably heard
a lot in biology class and no I do not
mean mitochondria is the powerhouse of
the cell which I mean it is instead I'm
talking about these two words structure
and function in biology the way bits and
pieces of an organism's body are built
from the materials to the shape to the
arrangements all these factors that
impact what an organism looks like its
structure are connected to what those
bits and pieces do the function now this
seems very simple but the point is that
structure and function are linked to
observe one is to make predictions and
inferences about the other and this is
something we can see across all levels
of biology from the shape of a bird's
wing to why mitochondria are the
powerhouse of the cell and of course
structure and function relate together
in the ways that an organism eats in
animals you might think of the different
types of teeth and mouths that reflect
both how and what a species eats but
this of course extends into the micro
cosmos as well not in terms of teeth of
course but in other structures that
influence an organism's behavior and
function as they pursue their meal of
choice and to see more of this let's
focus on one major group of eukaryotes
that encompass a multitude of eating
styles the ugly noids the you glean eyes
or you gleam heads are a large group of
flagella it's made up of well over a
thousand species the primary trait
uniting them are the strips of proteins
and microbes that line their bodies
creating a visible and striking
structure called the pellicle and some
you glenoid are green very very green as
we've explored before in a previous
episode their color comes from the
chloroplasts inside their body which
enable them to generate their own
nutrition via
photosynthesis but you glenoid x'
weren't always phototrophic now we're
used to thinking of plants as in some
way less developed than animals that
things that make their energy from the
Sun are more primitive than the things
that get their energy by eating other
stuff this actually is often the reverse
in the macro cosmos as is the story for
several eukaryotic lineages at some
point a long long time ago on
non-photosynthetic you glenoid consumed
a green algae but instead of merely
digesting that algae and turning it into
food it formed an endosymbiotic
relationship that would eventually turn
the algae into a chloroplast and turn
the fig atrophic you glenoid or one that
survives by eating stuff into a photo
trove so then the question becomes what
happened to the organisms in those
lineages that didn't make this dietary
switch well in the case of you glenoid
they continued evolving just with a
little less color and by comparing these
different you glenoid we can not only
see how different forms of eating
connect across evolutionary webs but
also how they become reflected in the
structure of the organisms themselves
let's start by explaining what the
non-photosynthetic you glenoid do for
food and you will notice here that I did
not say what they eat because they don't
all eat we can divide these colorless
you glenoid into three groups
you've got your bacteria vores your
Eukarya vores and your primary ozma
troves bacteria vores and Eukarya vores
are big atrophic meaning they rely on
Faygo cytosis to engulf and consume
their food where they differ of course
is what they eat which you can probably
guess bacteria vores like this Dynamat a
Monas which have no idea if i'm
pronouncing correctly usually go after
smaller organisms like bacteria while
Eukarya vores like to supersize their
meals and feed on larger microbial life
like eukaryotes the last category of you
glenoid x'
the primary ozma troves are the ones who
survive by absorbing nutrients from
their surroundings while phototrophs
and Figueroa are able to get food in
this way as well for primary ozma truths
this is it food wise its absorption or
bust so they do not eat they just allow
stuff to ooze into them
[Music]
there is an evolutionary trajectory to
these categories the bacteria for you
glenoid came first eukaryote vores
evolved from bacteria vores and then
phototrophs and primary ozma tros
evolved independently from Eukarya VARs
there are of course a few exceptions to
this neat narrative including a few ozma
trove species that evolved from
phototrophic you glenoid but for the
most part molecular phylogeny has held
up this order of dietary evolution and
what these organisms eat dictates how
much they interact with their
environment which in turn requires
different things out of their bodies
perhaps the most obvious divergence
compared to phototrophs
is that these colorless you clean oils
are colorless they don't have the green
chloroplasts that through their own
chemistry and structure helped
phototrophic you glenoid convert
sunlight into food in the case of the
[ __ ] roast then they need a way to grab
on to the organism they want to consume
and they do that with the help of a
feeding apparatus which unfortunately we
can't quite make out in our footage this
apparatus is made up of microtubules
that extend out from the front of the
cell and twist open to grab their prey
as the organism retract its feeding
apparatus back it drags the food and
with it but ozma truths and phototrophs
don't need that apparatus they're not
hunting anything down and so it might
not be much of a surprise that these
species tend to be marked by a reduction
or even a loss of the feeding apparatus
absorption or making your own nutrition
also requires a different sort of
motility compared to when you're on the
hunt
Ozma truths and phototrophs tend to swim
which allows them to explore and adjust
to sunlight and nutrition availability
along a water column meanwhile [ __ ]
roasts tend to glide along surfaces
which
Abel's them to search out and find prey
nearby this behavioral difference has
its basis of course in structural
differences most primary ozma truths and
phototrophs have two flagella but one is
much more apparent and active than the
other moving in a figure 8 shape that
helps the organism swim through the
water meanwhile FEA trophic flagella lie
on different ends of the cell and are
lined with hairs and rods that help the
organism glide their front flagellum
extends straight out constantly moving
to sense the world around them and for
some species their flagella is
multi-purpose they can use it to harpoon
prey and move it towards their feeding
apparatus but even though these Faga
truths may all ingest via phagocytosis
not all food is the same differences
that again are reflected in the bodies
of the hunters themselves you carry a
forest you glenoid x' tend to be larger
compared with their bacteria consuming
relatives and they also have more
película strips which allows them to be
less rigid their size and stretch lets
them not only consume bigger food but
also to morph their bodies according to
what they digest the premise of
structure and function is one of those
things that is so obvious that it's easy
to dismiss sometimes of course the way a
thing is built impacts what it is able
to do that's the basis of how we make
things that are useful whether they are
our homes or our cars but what makes
this concept so fascinating and powerful
in biology is that these pieces weren't
consciously assembled together they were
evolved at one point a bacteria voor you
glenoid had changed in some way that
gave way to a Eukarya voor and
eventually some descendant of that you
carry of or consumed a green algae
that set the stage for the photo truths
well another lost its feeding apparatus
to become a nas matru these differences
in structure and function linked
together a whole history of small
changes upon small changes connecting
organisms both past and present through
the much bigger differences we observe
today thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us and thank you as
well to audible for supporting this
episode
there are many audio books about the
micro cosmos that are available on
audible in I contain multitudes the
microbes within us and a grander view of
life author edy Yong takes us on a grand
tour through our microbial partners and
introduces us to the scientists on the
frontlines of discovery and he does this
with an enthusiasm for microbes that
might just rival our own and that is yes
available as an audio book on audible
we here at journey to the micro cosmos
know that seeing the world in different
ways opens us up to new ideas and new
ways of thinking and we know that
compelling stories have the ability to
do that same thing if you go to the link
in the description you can listen to I
contain multitudes along with many
audible originals which are exclusive
audio titles created by celebrated
storytellers from the worlds of sci-fi
journalism literature and more get your
first audiobook for free plus access to
all of the audible original monthly
offerings when you try out audible for
30 days by visiting audible.com slash
micro cosmos or by texting micro cosmos
2 500 500 and thank you to all of these
people whose names are on the screen
right now they are our patrons on
patreon which you can find at
patreon.com slash journey to micro if
you would like to help us
keep making this thing if you want to
see more from our master of microscopes
James check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby